قالت وسائل اعلام المحليه شماليه شرقي
سوريا اننا نحو 20 عنصرا من الفصائل
العسكريه المدعومه من ايران بينهم قياديه
قتلوا في قصف طال المنطقه الحدوديه
السوريه العراقيه بالقرب من البوكمال
برفيدرزور شرقيه سوريا وبحسب مصادر
للجزيره فان القصف طال صهاريجا محمله
بالمحروقات
ومواد لوجستيه وقالت المصادر المحليه ان
القافله تعرضت للقصف في حاله حركها من
المعبر الحدودي العراقي باتجاه سوريا وبست
وسائل اعلام المحليه والناشطون عبر من
السلط التواصل صورا
للحظه اندلاع النيران داخل معبر القائم
الحدودي بين سوريا والعراق عبر قصفان
مجهول لسادف المعبر بحسب وسائل الاعلام
وقالت مواقع اعلاميه مواليه للنظام السوري
ان القصف ادى ايضا الى اعصابي اكثر من 20
نصيرا محملا بالمحروقات كانت متجهه الى
لبنان عبر سوريا
ابو ليلى من بغداد مراسلون سامر يوسف سامر
ما هي ابرز المعلومات
يعني المتوفره حول ما جرى ودته
[موسيقى]
سلمى بدايه هناك اختلاف في الروايه
العراقيه اختلاف بسيط ولكن هناك اختلاف
وتباين في المعلومات على الرغم من ان لا
معلومات رسميه لا تعليقات رسمي لا بيان
رسمي صدر حتى هذه اللحظه بخصوص هذه
الحادثه التي وقعت فجر هذا اليوم في
الساعه الاولى من هذا اليوم ولكن المصادر
الامنيه تتحدث عن اربعه شاحنات مصادر
امنيه ومصادر محليه ايضا من هناك في اقصى
غرب الانبار عند المعبر الحدودي مع سوريا
معبر القائم وتقول بان هذه الشاحنات تعرضت
في قصه من مروحيه همم
صواريخ بمجرد عبورها الى الجانب السوري
وهناك شاحنات اخرى كانت ما زالت داخل
العراقيه
لم تتمكن من العبور حتى اعداد القتلى هناك
تباين بحسب المصادر المحليه وحتى المصادر
الامنيه وهو وسائل الاعلام ايضا همم
مواليه في الفصائل المسلحه عراقيه يتحدثون
عن اكثر من 20 قتيل ومصادر اخرى تتحدث عن
اربعه قتلى فقط اثنان من سائقي الشاحنات
واثنين اخرين من حرس الحدود العراقي حتى
هذه اللحظه هذه المعلومات المتوفره ولا
بيان رسمي لا حديث رسمي عن هذه الحادثه
بعض المصادر تقول بان هذه الشاحنات كانت
مخصصه لنقل المشتقات النفطيه همم ومتجهه
الى لبنان كما اسلفت مرورا بالاراضي
السوريه ولكن هذا المكان كان عاده ما
يتعرض الى عمليات قصف لقوات مسلحه لايضا
همم شاحنات تنقل المشتقات النفطيه وغيرها
خصوصا في العام الماضي شاهد العديد من هذه
الحوادث عند همم الحدود مع الاراضي
السوريه شكرا